first of all thank you for inviting me
to this Workshop um I understand that
the talk that I'm giving is different
from the previous talks both in terms of
application and also the methodology but
I thought uh in uh workshop on realtime
decision making it's worth mentioning uh
the you know the work that has been done
in um algorithmic you know questions uh
around online advertising um I'm also
thank F to nikil devanur for um uh
letting me use some of his slides and uh
Hamid and aronia for pointers to the
literature
um so online advertising is a big and
growing business in 2015 it was around
$60 billion was um uh spent on online
advertising alone it's the dominant
business model model uh for the uh a lot
of internet companies uh it helps a lot
of uh small and big businesses Thrive uh
a lot of the free services and content
that we use on the web is essentially
sponsored by online
advertising it's um uh by now it's a
very complex Market with uh hundreds of
players um uh you know not just
Publishers and advertisers uh you know
other players dis segregating
aggregating the traffic you know um
optimizing on behalf of the different uh
players and um um supplying data into
the system um it's the you know gives
rise to very interesting problems in
learning in mechanism design and
optimization It's actually an
interesting area of research because by
now most of the big companies have an
army of Engineers uh data scientists
researchers and uh the cycle from an
idea to implementation is becoming
shorter and shorter so this is an area
where you can actually have uh uh
immediate impact um there is a lot of
work in you know uh in this area I'm
going to just focus on one specific
problem and that's you know sort of more
the optimization um aspects um and I'm
going to review you know the work that
has been done over the past 10 years and
the impact of
that all right so probably you know
everybody here is familiar but let me
just review it quickly how ads are
typically sold um so you you there is a
you know bidding by the advertisers uh
it's done usually beforehand but
sometimes in real time now an add
opportunity arrives the add opportunity
could be somebody searching on a search
engine looking you know for a product or
um an add opportunity could be on you
know any other website I'll refer to as
a query then an ad should be selected
and priced and then charged and
typically here you know you have only a
fraction of a second uh maybe even in
terms of millisecond to to make your
decision um the allocations are related
to each other
um because of the you know sort of past
Behavior of a a specific ad or a
publisher or the information of the user
the ads that the user has uh uh clicked
on before or other P previous purchases
of the user but also they are related by
budget or demand constraints so um
typically every Advertiser has a certain
budget that they want to spend uh over a
certain period of time a day a week and
you know the the real time part of it
the decision making is the allocation
and the pricing of the
and
um I'm going to start with a very simple
model for this
um uh initially we called this the
AdWords problem but U probably the
online budgeted ad allocation is a
better um a better name for it imagine
you have n advertisers each has a budget
uh B1 to BN um you have queries arriving
online when a query arrives you can see
the bits so B A is the bid of Advertiser
a for ad I um you want to allocate the
query the add opportunity to one of the
advertisers and here we assume that once
you allocate uh your revenue is going to
be B uh the bit of The Advertiser for
the uh for the ad and right now you know
sort of simple um starting point the
objective is to maximize
Revenue so let me
just set up the notation so I have t
queries one through T and
advertisers the Bia is the ad the you
know budget is B Suba essentially I'm
trying to optimize this ma this uh
objective function the minimum of the um
the sum of the bits of the ads allocated
to The Advertiser and uh his or her
budget some of some all
advertisers is the problem
clear all
right so
um what's the simplest what's the first
algorithm one would think of um probably
you know greedy is the and actually that
was the first thing that was implemented
is um to allocate the add opportunity to
the you know every time a query arrives
among the advertisers who have not run
out of the budget give it to the person
give it to the advertiser that has the
highest beted that would be the most you
know sort of the simplest the myopic
strategy um it's also not hard to see
that the greedy algorithm does not give
you the optimal solution so here is a
simple
um example imagine you have two biders
two advertisers and one is is interested
in ads you know sort of about um showing
ads about books and also and CDs and
then beer 2 is only interested in um
showing ads about
Bock um both have a budget of
$100 now imagine your you know situation
is in such a way that initially people
only query about Bock so you get 100
queries about
Bock if your policy is greedy what you
do is that you allocate everything to be
there
one and then when the 100 CDs arrive the
only person who's interested has run out
of
money so you your total revenue is going
to be
$100 that's not the optimal thing to do
if you know if you had hindsight into
what's going to happen you will get a
100 bucks to be there too 100 CDs you
would get
$199 so this is you know what I showed
you is that greedy can give you a
revenue
that's as bad as half of the optimal now
it turns out that this is really the
worst case example so um the competitive
ratio of this algorithm which is the
ratio of the revenue over the revenue of
the best offline algorithm over all
sequences of the input is at least
half so the question that we fac and
this is around 10 years ago is that can
we do better uh is a factor half the
best possible um uh ratio and it turns
out that you can do better so you can
and come up with a you know a little
more clever allocation allocation rule
that um penalizes the biders that are
expending their budget uh too quickly so
it says instead of giving the query to
the person to the add Advertiser to the
bidder with the highest bit normalize
every bidder's bit by this factor of you
know 1 minus Alpha of a where Alpha is
the e to the power um minus unspent
fraction of budget of Advertiser a so if
you haven't spend much of your budget
you get don't get much penalized and
then as you spend more of your budgets
you know you get the the normalizing
factor in front of your bid gets closer
and closer to to zero and when you run
out of your budget uh your bid is thrown
out now it's a simple algorithm the
analysis is more complicated um and you
can show that the competitive ratio of
this algorithm is 1 - 1 / e that's
around
62 you can also show that
um that's the best possible so um uh
that's the you know you cannot do uh
better than that in this framework uh
the underlying assumption here is that
the ratio of bids to budgets is a small
but that's a reasonable assumption
usually the bids are of the order of
cents to Dollars and the budgets are
hundreds or thousands of
dollars any
questions what happens when the
assumption is false I'll get to it to
the
yeah all right now a few comments about
the model this is a you know there are
many simplifications I can talk for you
know an hour about like how many
different you know sort of how the
reality is different from the simple
model that we have considered but the
biggest ones is first of all we assume
that we have no knowledge about the
query
sequence um typically and especially for
the most popular queries uh you have a
lot you know you can look at the day of
the week you know day of the month and
look at the past history and come up
with an estimate of how many people
people are going to search for travel to
Vegas today now that's those are the
most popular queries if you look at the
long tail and you know the events you
know sort of the queries that are
related to um um everyday you know sort
of the um news related uh um uh events
those are actually very hard to predict
but for a large fraction of them we can
actually you know uh um have um uh have
a prediction have a prediction now
I assume that we charge the bidder his
or her bit um this is not what's this is
not what's happening in practice
typically there is a second price
auction so there are you know what
Google users for example is a
generalized second price auction a
number of um uh ads are chosen and they
are for example showed on a search page
you know on the right hand side and uh
essentially um
the the first bidder effectively pays
the um the bid of the second and the
second bidder second highest bidder pays
the bid of the third highest and so on
um now there are some you know sort of
uh contracts in display advertising
where first price is being used uh but
the dominant uh charging model is second
price um this one is also a big deal you
know we are assuming that you know I
have changed the v i allocating the um
I'm allocating the ads but now the
advertisers are going to respond to that
the
um um in fact um you can argue that
maybe uh you know if an Advertiser is
using his uh budget very quickly um you
want to let them you know run out of
budget because they're going to come
back and add more now the trouble here
is that uh if you look at most of the
advertisers actually have a you know
fixed budget and they don't respond very
quickly to the changes in the
environment all right so that's the
starting point um I'm going to um tell
you about a few you know sort of
follow-up works that gave us a better
understanding of this problem uh the
first one and this is shortly after by
bookbinder Jane and N was a primal dual
interpretation of the algorithm so uh
and this is very interesting and it's
going to be very useful so if you think
about the problem um the allocation
problem uh you can buy and R WR it as a
linear program so you're trying to
maximize your Revenue subject to the
amount that you're charging is the
amount that you're extracting from every
advertise that is no more than his or
her budget every query that arrives you
can give them to U at most one uh bidder
and um IAS are bigger than or equal to
zero you write the duo and the
complimentary slackness conditions here
are very similar to matching
LP so essentially it says that every
Advertiser gets a dual uh corresponding
to his or her budget that normalizes the
bid of that Advertiser so think about
this is the bit of The Advertiser this
is 1 minus Alpha of a alpha is the the
variable corresponding to um the the the
budget constraint of The Advertiser and
it says you know normalize the uh the
bid of The Advertiser by that factor and
then give it give the query to the uh to
the bidder with the highest normalized
bit now if you know you know the
sequence of queries you can solve this
linear program you can compute the
optimum Duo for every single individual
for every single bidder and you can
normalize their bids and make the
allocation in our problem since it's an
online problem we don't know the optimum
dual and essentially we are replacing
that with this function of the spent
budget so if you're spending your budget
it seems like you know we have you know
we have to correct for your normalizing
and we will we we adjust that so they
came up actually with a you know Primal
Duo algorithm that does the same thing
um now that helped in a sense that um
you know later on
um uh devanur and Hayes looked at the
stochastic version of this problem so
they said instead of assuming that the
queries are uh sent To Us by an
adversary you know we don't have any
information about the sequence of
queries arriving let's assume that they
are generated from a distribution so
let's say you know they are coming from
you know an i ID distribution every time
it's you know sort of the uh a query
sample from a distribution as sent to
you or uh the set of queries is fixed
and you we just get a random order um
from that Set uh well in that case you
know it's not hard to see that one thing
that you can do is that you can wait uh
for a certain period of time uh learn
the distribution solve the linear
program learn the Dual variables Corr
you know compute the Dual variables
corresponding to every bidder and then
solve the
problem uh the competitive ratio here
you know goes to one as bit to budget
goes to zero so essentially it says you
know waste Epsilon of of the queries to
learn what's going on and use the you
know use that to um now if you look here
the the dependence on the Epsilon and uh
on the number of um um uh a number of
advertisers is not too good so this is
not you know useful for practice yet but
you can do um build on that idea um this
idea of you know sort of doubling you
know correcting as you get more samples
as used in a uh in other applications so
you make the learning a little bit
smarter you make the dependence a a bit
better
um the nice ni thing about this
framework is that it was later also
generalized to when you have other
packing constraints not just budget
constraints let's say in the you know um
you come up with a budget and you say
you don't want to spend more than this
much money total but you say on a
particular locality you don't want to
spend more than 50% of your budget on or
you want to have uh to spend your budget
you know divided a certain way across
genders or certain you know across
demographics so um it will make your
linear program more complicated but you
can solve it and you can apply the same
framework we should we can think of T is
not known here the number of stages or
the number of no you should assume that
it's
known or is known in
expectation um it was also generalized
later to display advert ising so in the
the case of display advertising it's a
little bit you know the setup is a
little bit different usually the
advertisers sign a contract with the
publisher and they the publisher
guarantees a certain number of uh uh
Impressions so you know I'm going to
show your ad at least you know 10
million times over the next you know uh
uh month or so um now the capacity is
fixed but you're trying to maximize the
value of the uh of the ads for your
customer and the value depends on the
characteristics of the user um so it's a
different uh packing problem um and uh a
similar dual based allocation uh that's
um uh can be applied here instead of
a a
multiplicative um normalization here you
need an you know additive uh uh
normalization and you know it's actually
put in practice uh the same way um later
um Deva Jane uh Shivan and Wilkins um
looked at um they improved the way the
the system learns the arrival of the
queries um they call this continuous
learning and um they turned in sort of
the normalization and you know actually
you can see the formula is not very
different from the you know sort of the
original work except that the penalty is
first you know is is this is the
following way first you do the
calculation you know you solve your LP
you collect all the information you have
about the past and you come up with a
target a spend rate for every Advertiser
so you think about halfway through the
day this particular Advertiser based on
my simulations should have spent around
a quarter of his or her budget and what
you do is that you come up with a
actually a severe penalty function from
for deviating uh from that and
um um this you know sort of has a you
know convergence rate that's you know
nearly optimal so the dependence is
improved both in terms of dependence on
n and also the dependence on U Epsilon
so this formula is what you you know
Microsoft is using for allocating its uh
uh um
advertisement um then you know sort of
there are many generalizations um for
example what happens when you have you
know multiple ads on pages remember I
told you that you know typically you you
know you don't choose one ad you choose
a collection of ads and once you choose
the collection of ads you know how much
your revenue is because you know the
beid of each person right so in that
case your linear program is not a simple
packing you have to write a what what's
called a configurational linear program
that looks at you know all this Comm
communial choices the lp is much bigger
but we also have the computational
resources we can solve that
um then um there is this sort of idea of
mixing you know worst case and
stochastic so imagine you have some uh
idea about the distribution of the
queries so you have some expectation of
what's going to happen today but because
of external events it starts changing
you start getting queries about a
particular uh IND indidual uh part you
know sort of you know let's say uh uh
Prince dies and now everybody is trying
to buy you know download songs from
Prince uh in that case essentially this
deviation this spikes are quite um uh
valuable for the Publishers so they have
to have a way of deviating from their
existing you know uh framework um we did
the work you know some time ago and uh
it's been actually generalized and uh
used and uh again you know used in
practice uh also um the objective
function uh for most of these Publishers
is not exactly um short-term Revenue
they're trying to optimize the
experience of the user as well so that's
where the relevance comes in but it can
be plugged into the um objective
function so um when it comes to
implementations in practice this is one
of the few places you know few areas
where there's actually publish result on
what each specific company is using uh
in Google and you know uh uh double
click um so the learning based algorithm
that I told you you know briefly is the
one that's being used they you they also
have this idea of calling optimized
throttling so this is essentially
throttling is for the advertisers who
are using their budget too quickly um
what they do is that they um uh you know
optimize between a you know variety of
parameters to um uh to slow down the uh
the the rate at which an Advertiser is
using his
budget the the Primal dual and control
Loop that I told you like that a
specific formula is the one that's being
used by Microsoft um there are also you
know actually the simpler formulas are
the ones that are used by you know the
um U mobile companies like admob and you
know uh in mob for their native ads are
using the much you know sort of simpler
um so the the you know
the feeling that I have you know sort of
some is you know sort of the over the
past 10 years moved from a simple uh
idea all the way to something that's
being used at a scale it's reliable it's
um uh um being used you know like a you
know technology on a uh on an everyday
basis the there is this there are still
questions in
um you know sort about in this area of
you know budget
optimization but um they're probably
better solved at the companies
themselves because they have access to
the data and they can run experiments
there are the more interesting questions
are in Dynamic mechanism design you know
after 15 years now is actually a good
time to take a look at the structure of
the auctions and see whether we want to
continue the generalized second price
auctions whether we actually want to run
auctions for advertising or given that
how much information now the sellers
have about the goods they sell the ad
opportunities maybe they want to move to
a fixed price scheme even in in an
auction you know the question of how to
put Reserve prices given that the market
is thinning in a sense that the
advertising ERS are in the um the
advertisers are more and more interested
in a specific ads so like you know the
for the user that has made a particular
purchase in the past and lives in a
particular zip code and you know sort of
has this long uh Vector of attributes
once you have queries that are like that
when you look at the number of people
who are bidding on a particular
opportunity like that is a smaller uh so
you have to find a way to put Reserve
prices so that your revenue does not
drop um there are questions in learning
you know about you know there are all
these learning algorithms you know
machine learning algorithms that are
running in the background trying to
figure out the characteristics of the
user of The Advertiser of the of the
publisher and they are interacting with
um uh um um with selfish agents with you
know sort of agents that are um um
making a lot of money and uh
the mixture of the you know sort of the
learning optimization and the mechanism
design there are quite you know sort of
um uh quite a lot of interesting
problems in that domain there are
surveys written you know we wrote a book
chapter in algorithmic Game Theory on
the subject there is you know these two
Kur and mea from um Google also have
plenty of interesting research problems
I'm happy to talk to you about um um
um all of them um with the caveat
that I have this nagging feeling that
there is enough computational and brain
power dedicated to getting users to see
an ad to click on an ad and make a
purchase of something they probably
don't need
uh
um you know a more interesting maybe a
more philosophical question
is you know in the context you know sort
of uh online algorithms um when you look
at the adversarial nature of competitive
analysis uh it seems like you know when
you're optimizing against uh an
adversary and a very powerful adver
adversary you end up designing
algorithms for that are that are very
conservative so I really like this from
the uh online compet competition and
competitive analysis book you know if
you can see it's you know the algorithm
designer on a tight rope trying to
balance between many options and then
the adversary is sending you know shock
waves trying to you get him off balanced
um now you know you can think about
optimizations you know when you have
distributional
assumptions in my experience most of the
distribution assumptions are often too
optimistic and also the algorithms that
you come up with depend you know sort of
heavily or you know are s quite
sensitive to the distributional
assumptions
um in this particular application we
managed to you know marry the insights
from you know these different ways of
modeling and come up with u uh robust
algorithms but I I still think there is
a lot of di dialogue that has to be done
between these two ways of thinking uh
about a
problem um and you know sort of lastly
the problem that I'm you know quite
interested in that Luca asked about um
so let's think about for a second the
very special case of this problem where
the budgets are one and the bits are
zero or one so that's an online matching
problem all right it's um was initially
studied by U um K vazon and vazon in
this beautiful paper you know they look
at they POS the problem as an online
matching imagine you have a set of girls
and you have a set of boys arriving one
by one so the first boy you know arrives
and then you see which girls are
interested in it at this moment you have
to decide who to match the boy to so
let's say this person then the next boy
arrives nobody's
interested uh the next one you know
between this three you can match it
between match the boy to one of the two
girls um again in this case you know any
maximal allocation so as long as when
there's a you know you have a boy that
one girl is interested in you allocate
the boy to that uh you you can get
Factor half the work of car Von and voni
shows that you can get the competitive
ratio of 1 minus 1 over e and that's
Optimum but you can ask the question
about the stochastic version so
imagine that I give you the bipartite
graph I'll give you the set of girls and
boys and tell you that from the set of
boys I'm going to sample independently
every time and there is a you know prob
you know I give you the probability that
I sample from the set of boy the
probability that each boy is chosen and
I tell you that I'm going to sample
independently uh what's the optimum
allocation algorithm so now we can talk
about the optimum allocation alth right
this a stochastic uh
input uh now it's not too hard to show
that the problem is NP hard what's the
best approximation algorithm um the best
approximation ratio is unknown there is
you know some work in this area
initially by Feldman at all we did some
work though and the work of the BSS X I
think is the best known um approximation
ratio but for such a simple Central
problem uh it's unfortunate that there
is still such a gap between the lower
and upper bound uh for the pro so
um if want to sort of if I want to end
with the specific in a sort of uh
concrete problem um here it is thank
you
questions
yes so uh if I'm not mistaken the all
the advertising results that you
mentioned uh assume that the advertisers
know precisely the utility that they're
getting from each uh
opportunity uh but in
reality they're probably learning the
value of opportunities from the quality
of uh the matching results that they get
over time so in fact there is sort of a
longer term uh behavior of the
system uh that is affected by the
quality of service that each Advertiser
is getting are there
any uh results that try to look into
this yes um yeah so very true so you can
look at the problem in two ways one is
that the advertiser is trying to learn
which queries you know which keywords
which search engine you know is giving
you know sort of the best result uh to
him or to her and um you can set up
actually an optimization typically in a
sort of regret minimization framework
there uh and there are actually quite a
lot of there are research papers and
there are also quite a lot of companies
that do this on behalf of the uh of The
Advertiser but um another movement is
you know on the side of Publishers or
let's say Google or you know sort of
search engines is that they say instead
of charging you for click you know click
per se does not have any value for you
we're going to charge you for the action
that's profitable for you so let's say
we're going to charge you when there is
an acquisition that takes and then you
know the learning can take place when
the real signal and you know sort of
Google can do the optimization and that
now there is this question of whether
you want to share all this information
with an already powerful uh search
engine that may get into your business
tomorrow uh so depending on uh yeah so
depending on the cont you know sometimes
the optimization is done at the
advertiser level or at the publisher or
the search engine
level yes you mentioned the point of
charging for a click so now going back
to the problem formulation that you had
where you said that you're going to look
at the bid for each opportunity and give
say give it to the highest bidder it's
not just the bid but also the
probability of that ad getting clicked
that needs yes yeah so that's another
yeah so that's another simplification
but this one is not that big a deal
because you can always normalize the bit
by The Click through
rate multiply it yeah so it's the
expected
value is the Strategic behavior of
people in terms of choosing their
budgets is there evidence of that or is
it just always the best strategy to
update your budget as soon as your
adverts shown I mean it would set an
infinite budget right so it depends on
the nature of the advertiser so one way
to think about it is that uh it depends
on the marginal value of the additional
traffic so let's say if you know the the
additional traffic that comes to you is
worth you 50 cents per click and you can
get it with 40 cents then why do you
need a budget just the more the merer
but um a lot of advertisers have
capacity constraints so they you know if
you are a nightclub in New York City you
can only fit so many people in if you're
you
know selling T-shirts you have only so
many t-shirts in your system so the
budgets are usually reflecting that the
capacity constraint there are also some
organization issues a lot of times you
know the VP of marketing has a certain
budget you know so many million dollars
you know a quarter and they just want to
spread it and you use it over time and
use it so effectively I mean one
interpretation is what you're doing is
effectively shaving the bid for people
in order that they get the correct bid
to run out their budget in the way that
suits them um no not really because uh
essentially it says if you're spending
your budget too quickly I'm going to
slow you down
um so that your you know your money is
spend uh um uh you know spread evenly
over the
days um so that should only help
you yes sir could you uh restate your
model of uh online stochastic magic sure
so you're given a graph um a bipar graph
and uh you know on the right hand side
for the boys you have a probability for
as assigned to um each node now what
happens is that um every time I'm going
to choose one boy from the set with
probability uh proportional to the you
know with with the probability given to
that person and I'm going to do this
independently and I'm going to do this K
times and every time you get you know a
boy a sample you have to decide which
girl you're going to assign it to it's
done with repetition and it's done with
repetition and you know the distribution
you know distribution yeah you know the
number you know you know the number of
samples and you know the distribution uh
from which you you
sample so all the girls are there from
the beginning yes so you know the girls
are there from the beginning you also
know the
graph there are agnostic versions also
where if you just know there's a
distribution but you don't know what the
distribution is right yeah so there are
agnostic versions there are also
versions in which um um you know you're
going to I get the the this set of boys
but um oh yeah you
don't you don't know the graph but you
just know that the set of boys are given
to you in a random order but this is the
simplest model that you know what are
the gaps in terms of what we know about
the approximation isue um I think it's
like point it's not well it's not it's
easy to get 1 - 1 / e you just ignore
the distribution you can improve it to
point
79 uh and in terms of upper bounds we
know very little
so so the best of both words between
worst case and stochastic nature of the
problem as well as the particular
adversarial lower bound that you showed
initially kind of is reminiscent of
smooth analysis um so is there any work
on that line
yeah
um for many of the applications so a
smooth analysis is actually you know
sort of it's amazing it works for say
simple because it just allows you to
perturb the
instance slightly and here most of the
instances divorce case instances are if
you perturb them slightly still they
have the
same thank you very much thank you